hey guys I'm Ryan right hey I'm just
Lena Meyer we're gonna review the
trailer today for minions Walter look
these adorable little freaks are headed
to Orlando to kill if I was amazing
that's who I work for
[Music]
what about you any challenge or a talent
doesn't it feel so good
[Music]
work for me all your dreams come true
respect I'll fill them down with a
bedtime story
there were the creepy to come work for
her one day
the pig looks pretty adorable that was
the most adorable like tree I've ever
seen I think they're gonna pull this off
I've had my concerns because the
meetings are such like side-characters
and despicable mean like they're funny
because they're two dimensional
characters but I feel like this was
gonna be a fun movie absolutely I love
that they have their own language but
they're so expressive at the same time
knowing exactly what they're saying
they're just like have their own
language they're adorable as [ __ ] god I
want to pet one of them I want to speak
minion yeah yeah banana but not because
the other shows weren't showing this
they they have human being characters in
this and I like the new characters
actually like Sandra Bullock's character
um was it Prince of Christmas overkill
yeah exactly
she's like the evil yeah she's like them
little fish yeah she's like female guru
but chances are it's not gonna work out
with her or something like that I think
that's gonna be a really funny character
I like that little side animation they
had the Three Little Pigs story yeah
that wasn't perfect it looks like
they're having a lot of fun with this
film like taking more advantage of the
animation world yes they can creative
the despicable Me franchise is one of
those movies that like I'm not dying to
watch them but when I do watch them I
have a great time yeah as far as comedy
genre goes it looks like it's gonna be
funny
that moment was hilarious when she's
telling the story and then that
sleep like they're so hilarious cuz they
kind of represent society and weird I
don't quite I don't know how but there's
something about them because all that
shines is their personality not the
details of what they're saying yeah yeah
yeah it's great stuff yeah it's like a
kid movie but it's so like I enjoy like
I thoroughly enjoy watching like movies
like innovation like this so it's like
brilliant
does that make you uh more like sexually
turned on watching animated no it's like
such a pure like joy it's like I'm like
a little kid but you're gonna like
certain ones I'm making love can be
considered what is joy we're not getting
sexual about minions
we never know I mean those minions could
be probably really funny fast [ __ ]
kids if you're watching huh
think about the minions tonight you
might be a 12 year old boy who's like oh
man what's happening with my called
erection and ejaculation thinking about
the minions and I'll make it good for
all you know you might attract a yellow
[ __ ] when you're older tryna help out
the kids trying to make a
family-friendly movie breakin alright
Ryan Gelinas his project director called
my energy and I'm just trying to tamper
with her image a little bit by talking
about some cool stuff I'm a nice girl
I'm a good girl yet this man your
boyfriend says I don't know fight you
know I will I'm invidiously like good
girl like no Cherubini I will figure out
off the beany down nothing but the
beating oh my god is it really the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects Julia's product director of
color my energy I'm going to be
performing there this Saturday so is
Veronica first time performing music
live and color my Energy's an awesome
event you can check out her channel or
you can also go to Veronica's channel
and check out the vlog of color Manor G
so you can really get a full themed
understanding of what's going on yeah
gonna be fun I'm excited last thing my
internet is not up cuz 18 tu vs. a [ __ ]
I'm letting you guys know that right now
[ __ ] you AT&T u-verse I hope you come
across this video one day so you can
know how shitty your services they were
supposed to install my internet and they
practically told me oh yeah we forgot to
do it so I don't have shoutouts up right
now
and so I can't do shoutout so we go to
facebook.com slash the real reject
shoutouts where you can earn yourself a
shout out but say something interesting
like chelina um likes to be told she is
a good smelling onion in bed really come
on we've been told that or some no never
ever ever
I feel like flowers now you guys get it
better
that's what shout out so I'm finding out
facts like that